大家好
這是楊樹凱講
今天是2024年5月23號晚上8點整
我今天想要來跟各位分享一本書
是我最近看完的一本書叫巨人思維
實際上這本書也感謝天下雜誌
天下雜誌他有寄這本書給我
他會寄這本書給我
我也要謝謝老莫
因为老莫的介绍
我就认识他们
也谢谢吴小姐
企划部吴小姐
也跟她说声抱歉
因为我大概拿到这本书
可能是在
我忘记了是在三月还是四月的时候
可是我直到最近
五月中旬
我才把这本书
把它读完
而且读这本书
是在飞机上读的
就我把这本书
从香港带去芝加哥
又带去纽约
后来又带去洛杉矶
所以我回到香港
最终在香港到
我现在在台北
回到台北这段路上
我就把它读完
分了很多段
这本书陪着我旅行的半个地球
而且一直放到包包里面
所以我去到哪里都背着这本书
这本书没有说太重
而且它也没有很厚
大概1.5公分厚
可是我今天突然想要讲这本书
是因为我觉得这本书
刚好今天
今天什么事情都过完了
所以我想有时间来分享一下这一本
那这本呢
请大家放心
我不会讲太多书里面的一些东西
没有爆雷
我只会讲几个重点
那我刚才跟出版社有跟他询问
就是我如果只有显示目录的话
应该不犯规吧
他们说不会
这个算是有点半公开资料
好那我们就开始
大概有三
我分三张来讲
就是他这个整本书里面
其实有分三部曲
那第一部第二部第三部呢
其实全部都是在讲交易哦
你不要以为前面可能讲他自己又干嘛
其实他从讲自己开始就已经开始讲交易
而且他一开始书有讲的很透彻
就是这本书看完的人
有可能会被他劝退
劝退离开这个市场
我觉得蛮好玩的
他对这个如果你是初心者
就是第一次踏进这个市场的人
我非常非常非常的推荐你看这本书
非常推荐
就是说如果你可能就是也不知道读什么
我觉得不要先去书店乱买书
你先买这本书
买完这本书之后
你要去看什么其他的技术
分析什么东西你再去
这本书除了讲一些心法之外
心法是一定会讲的
每个人都会讲
但是它里面着重在于说
他自己本身碰到的一些难题
然后后来怎么解决这难题
然后后来又怎么会踏入
那个领域去的
他有把这些过程
就是很
很具细迷的描述出来
比如说他从玩台股
打古旗
打古旗打一打之后
怎么会打到现货那边去
因为他已经
那个量体已经无法满足他了
那后面你就说
他有空余的时间
结果下午又去打欧盘
然后美盘开始的时候
又再打美盘
然后他天生的一个交易魂在他身上
其实有交易魂的这种人
我碰到的也蛮不少的
那我自己本身其实也算是一半的交易魂
在身上流窜
所以只要碰到类似这样的人
你跟他讲什么
他其实有时候跟你聊天
你聊到睡着
但是你只要跟他讲到说
我跟你讲
昨天晚上那個怎麼突然5分鐘之間殺了幾百點什麼的
他會眼睛變得非常亮
然後就直接跟你講
對啊怎樣怎樣
整個的交易魂就會上來
我覺得如果你是
不管是你是玩票性質的來做交易
還是說你只是說想要增加一點理財投資
或者是說你是專心自製
想說以後我要走上這條路
我要走向把交易当作是我一个正直
就是成为职业型的交易者
我觉得你身边
你的身边的朋友
一定要有这样的人存在
你知道为什么吗
一不会无聊
有话题不会无聊
然后第二个就是说
经由很多的讨论
你们会产生出新的交易的东西
我现在讲的是题外话
書上他有寫到這樣子
類似的
就說他裡面有寫到說
有的時候他會有個小群組
然後裡面在聊
聊些什麼
那鼓起怎麼打
鼓起幹什麼
甚至說他在有一天晚上
很深夜的時候
就凌晨的時候
那有發生一些事情
然後他們認為就是說
現在如果打的話
會把幾個
因為流動性不好
凌晨三四點
流動性一定很不好
會把夜盤開止期
一些或是選擇權
一些有些東西把它弄到很不好的地方去
然後他們幾個聊完之後就算了
大家去睡覺
結果隔天開平盤
然後調整一下部位又回來
就沒有造成其他奇怪的傷亡
這一段其實它裡面有一些
也就是說我還是回到剛剛的話題
就是大家你在做交易的時候
你身邊最好是有朋友
不管是辦公室同事
或者是說在OP凱文群組裡面
或者是說你的什麼同學
高中同學 大學同學也好
就身邊一定要有一些有交易魂的人
這樣子你一不會無聊
第二個你可以教學想長
第三你可以得到一些新的啟發
當然你也幫助他得到一些新的啟發所以有的人說什麼三個臭皮像勝過一個諸葛亮吗就是这个道理讲这个其实是我看到他整篇
就是整本书我觉得一个对新手来讲
一个蛮重要的
就是你不要一个人埋锅造饭
这是很危险的
因为你有可能就是往一条死巷子
一直不断的钻下去
一直钻牛角尖
这个是开场牌
我第一个阶段想要跟各位分享的
其实他的第一步第二步第三步
我大概分三个阶段来跟大家讲
其实最重要的东西是在第一步
我光第一步跟第二步前半步
我看了两遍
不是说怎么会这样子
怎么不把一次看完
没有我是看了两遍
然后最后第三步我只看了一次
第一步跟第二步我看了两遍
我总结了几个观点
第一个就是说
如果你刚进这个市场
你还看不懂的话
多看
找机会
找商品
找市场
他其实第一步
其实又给大家一个image
为什么要找机会
找商品找市场
因为你在不同的商品中
不同的市场中
就是会找到机会
就是风险与报酬不对称的地方
才有机会
风险与报酬不对称的地方才有机会
这个是他第一步里面
最让我印象深刻的一段精神
他的话或许不是这样讲
但是我消化完了之后
我觉得就是风险与报酬不对称地方
就有机会
好像是他讲
个股跟个股期之间
还有就是说讲一些海期
跟台子期它的那个联动性
然后还有讲到说一些全职股跟台子期
在发动的时机点
也稍微有点不一样的时候
就在第68页
可是题外话
第68页那页我把它折起来
为什么呢
因为我觉得
等一下我看一下书
是不是我讲错页数
这样算有点爆雷
小爆雷
但是我觉得我没有讲内容
我是讲页数而已
这样会不会吸引大家去买一些
买来看
我看是不是68页
对没错68页
因为机型还不错
68页的时候
他有讲到说台子企跟台子企的那些成分股
全职股的部分
他的发动的先后存序
但是这个有一点不太正确
以实物上来讲的话
不是他写的那样子
他整本书我觉得只有这个地方有点小bug
但是其他我觉得我没有太多意见
但这一块也是
我没有怪他是说
而是说一般人看到市场上那样的一个反应
比如说台子期间拉
然后后面全职跟着拉
他里面讲的是说外资先做台子期间
然后开始部分人去做拉台动作
然后后面全职组
全职股然后跟着上
其实一般人都会这样想
但实际上在外资投行自行部的操作里面
不会是这样子
他刚好是反过了
他是等
等
你这样我不是剧透
他就等市场上如果有
期貨假設期貨瞬間拉抬上去
那上面空單
期貨空單成交之後
就趕快把現貨一攬子部位補起來
實際上是這樣子
好了我順道講完了
好那這是還有一個就是說
他講賺賠比才是重點
他的基本上他的交易只有50%勝率
那講這一點其實
大家可能會講說你這個老生常談
大家都知道啊
他為什麼還寫在書裡面
其實說真的
你如果去問一些在交易的那些交易者
搞不好很多人還搞不清楚
這個是什麼樣的一個邏輯
很多人還是追求勝率要高
我勝率要九成
我勝率要什麼九成五
什麼九成九
就是追求高勝率
可是高勝率其實不一定會賺錢
怎麼說呢
我舉個例子
如果你去做那个选择权卖方
假设你是做卖跨市或卖乐市
那乐市有的人喜欢做乐市
是因为他卖出了是可以架得远远的
那个履约架上面履约架跟下面履约架
都是架得远远远
可能这在行情的5% 6%之外
那结算日到期的就稳稳的收那些权利金
很爽
可是玩这种策略的人都知道
你可能十次都会爽爽的收
收干
吸好吸满
可是往往会十几次会发生那么一次冲出去
而且那一次冲出去
会把你之前前面十几次的全部一次拼回来
甚至倒赔
你九成的胜率
可是那一次的错
一次就是让你回家
所以这个就是
他讲的赚赔比才是重点
50%的胜率
其实你知道维持到
在我认为
三十几%四十几%的胜率都没有问题
重点是你的赚赔比
我这个是题外话
这不是书里面写的
我认为真正的赚赔比
就是像是profit factor
简单而言就是说
你赚一次钱
可以让你输几次
如果在赚钱跟输钱
一定的金额之下
一样的这个情况之下
如果你赚一次可以让你赔1.3次
我就觉得这个是合格的
我再听一次再讲一次
就是说你赚一次钱
可以让你赔1.3次
那这样的策略其实就是一个好策略
你不要去管那个胜率
那个胜率一定是很shit
可能就是什么3成5了
了不起4成
但是如果他的赚倍比是1.3
这比例是1比1.3以上的话
其实就是好的
那我比较喜欢看到的是2就是你赚一次可以让你赔两次那你这个long turn來講的話你長期操作這樣下來的話那其實你就會賺錢我這各位就是
我就是引申引述他
賺baby才是重點
然後還有一個就是說他
他裡面有講到認輸
他算認輸的這一個篇幅講的不太多
但是我覺得這很重要
我特別把它拿出來提
就是說你要懂得認輸
如果你不認輸
凹单绝对会死
大家都知道
又在讲这个东西
这种东西干嘛写进书里面
可是这个我很认真的讲
他里面有举一些例子
就是说你如果不认输的话
你再过来你就没有什么东西
可以再去追再去冲
他里面讲到一个很有趣的解释
就是赚钱跟赔钱
分子跟分母的问题
他说你做交易的话
你把公司拉开
赔钱把它当做分母
赚钱把它当分子
大家所要追求的就很简单
我要极可能的去增大我的分子
就是赚钱那部分要增大
然后我赔钱的那部分
就是分母那块我要把它缩小
如果这样子的话
我是不是可以增大我整个profit
听这个好像
不是在讲废话
就是赚多一点
赔少一点
都是讲废话
可是很难
因为你要赔少一点
代表说你有时候你要懂得去认输
这是很违反人性
你有时候那个手伸出去
要按下那按钮
所以你按不下去
所以你必须要养成一个星星
去训练你自己
就是你要懂得去认输
这个他书里面有稍微提到一下
那你各位现在有看到这些
我把他的序
那个目录有放在投影给大家看
那第一部其实就是你按照
他的这个序这样看
那个目录这样看
其实很清楚明了
他大概书里面会跟你讲些什么东西
我觉得第一部
还有第二部
如果可以的话
你先看两遍
你看完这两遍之后
你再去看第三部
你就大概有这个
你不要一口气就一口气就一口气读完
一口气读完我觉得没有什么意思
好险我是因为坐飞机起飞降落断断续续的
中间因为灯光太暗
所以我就合起来用那个
所以造成我就是读完前面读完两次
后来我发现读完两次之后才知道说
原来你之前你从小或是
从十几年前借出的市场的时候
原来也会这样子
它是一个成长的过程
所以我建议你112看完之后
倒带回去再重新看1
从1再开始看
但你看第二遍会看得比较快
你就可以知道说原来是这样
然后你到第三段的时候
他就会明了说原来作者是希望
希望你把这些东西带进去到最后
好那第三步来讲的话
就会比较稍微进入那种像是交易类的东西
他其实后面来讲的话
他会告诉你说
一般人会用什么技术分析
像是他上面这边讲的
用技术分析
然后去观察市场上的共识
他其实不是要叫你用技术分析
别搞错了
如果你有买书去看的话
其实他这一段
其实他并不是
我觉得作者想表达的是
他并不是很赞同用技术分析
像一些网红
然后网络老师教你怎么做
然后你就是怎么跟着他怎么做
他其实会用技术分析来去看
因为他认为全市场
就是大家都是看这些技术分析
所以他是以一个第三者的角度
去反看这个市场
所以当KD怎么样
MACD怎么样
或是什么东西是什么样
然后这个市场开始这样走
我说因为大家都在看这种东西
所以他是以一种
他先就是我们讲的什么
就是think outside of the box
就是从这个箱子外面再去反沾
再去看
看大家在干嘛
那再找机会
就是刚才我讲的
找风险报酬不对称的地方
然后再切入
这个就是他整个交易的心法这样子
你看他这个第十
那个第三部的那样
第十三个章节就写说
市场上充满了风险报酬不对等机会
其实很多
他里面有举很多的例子
然后在他这整本书里面
他一直推崇一个理念
就是说你不要以为你是穷学生
或是说你不要以为刚开始什么都不懂
他其实一直很鼓励大家
就是说你在很年轻的时候
你的本钱就是要一直不断地学习
多看多听多学
一直不断地去做研究
而且要反复的去
在你的交易上去做一个review
他说他每天做交易
他花最多时间就是在review
我想不管是在
像是我曾经有访问过那个常庆
或者是说像高大哥
或者是说像龙哥那些人也好
他们其实有个共同的特点
就是说有时候就是要
你要检讨
检讨你自己
不管你赚钱要检讨
你说哇你疯了
赚钱要检讨什么
就赶快去party
没有你赚钱要检讨
你要記住
你為什麼這次可以賺這些錢
那可不可以複製
還是說原本可以賺更多
如果怎麼樣還可以再賺更多的
可惜沒關係學起來
當然你輸錢的時候也要檢討
這是奇怪
怎麼搞到最後一直在那邊搞停損
到底是市場問題
還是個人問題
還是券商期貨商報價端的問題什麼問題都要挑出來然後當然有時找不到问题所以就怪市场但我跟你讲市场永远是对然后这个大概是第三步的前半步了
那最后一个就是说
他第三步的最后面
一个操作片
那这边其实
他的业数很少
可是我觉得蛮值得看
那这边是真的不能剧透
我觉得他这样讲也是也很有道理
而且也剛好我最近我去五月初的時候
我跑去芝加哥
我在CME那邊Aurora機房
我們公司我們自己裝我們的機器在裡面
我們就直接收CME的Market Data
然後直接用晶片做切片之後
我們就想趕快快速的交易
所以這個也是為什麼要把機器
摆在Aurora
摆在日本东京CC2的机房里面
就是这个原因
因为我发现就是说
你就是要找寻
我刚才讲的嘛
就是找寻机会
对
那如果你在台湾
只是搜一般期货商
券商的这个Market Data
说真的
那个都不够
而且那个都是事后
那个都不知道
原生地不知道交易到哪里去了
对
所以你要去那个市场
去跟他compet的时候
我会很认真的建议各位
就是说如果你真的走到
就是很专职
不管是说你是追求速度
还是你是追求
你是做计量的也好
其实你要去做任何研究的时候
你必须要去更深刻认识那个市场
更深刻认识那个市场
有很多种方式
但是就交易这个环节来说
像你要做研究的话
在我们开播之前
有跟一个群友在开麦克风聊天聊了一下
其实你要研究一个市场
你必须要去研究它
Fooltick的Market Data
所以Fooltick的Market Data
就是说是百分之百的完整的
你所有的报价的那些资料源
要百分之百完整
而不是说我跟一个券商拿或期货商拿
他们那个资料都是有缺陷的
為什麼有缺陷呢
它的準確度是百分之百準確的
沒有問題
而它的完整度
我們探討是它的完整度不夠
你從券商 期貨商 播客給你
你用家裡的電腦把它錄起來
或者說它整個拿給你
它其實它播送給你都是八分之一秒的數據
甚至如果你是大戶走大戶通道的話
它給你看的數據有可能稍微多一點
多一倍出來就1.16秒的數據
就1秒鐘切16刀
然後再分送給你
但是就算是1秒鐘播16次給你
那個完整度也只有大概8成出頭一點
8成2到8成了不起8成5
所以說你是從7成變成8成多而已
你無法達到100%
那無法達到100%的時候
你做那些Market的那些研究
其實就會失真
然後你回測做什麼的就會怪怪的
那有時候沒有啦我只是說
我只是看能不能就trigger這樣子而已啊
那我就舉個例子嘛
那你看A片的時候
你那個馬賽克要打
有三分之一就打馬賽克嘛
對啊
偶爾一點點是沒關係
三分之一打馬賽克不是很奇怪嗎
好所以說總結一下
這本書我就一開始跟各位講一樣
我非常推薦你是新手中手老手
尤其是新手你一定要買來看
你說這本書三四百塊
我覺得很值得去買
如果你聽完我這一個又很好奇
但是又不想買
沒關係你去成品
成品架上他現在好像是也是在燙銷書
已經過了這幾個月還是在前三名
我去成本好像看到好像在第二第三名
你就去翻
但是我覺得
你翻了前面的50頁60頁之後
你就會想把它帶回家了
我是覺得這本書真的很值得買
當然有沒有業配
算業配吧
因為也感謝天下他送我這本書
但是說真的
我其實沒有拿這本書
我也會去買
因為有幾個人跟我講過這本書
就我們辦公室也會教議員
他有跟我講說這本書要看完了
他從裡面得到一個想法
然後他現在在弄
我們有想到一個好玩的交易策略
但是交易策略其實可以用在我們機器上面
做高評
但是我覺得如果
如果巨人節本人有聽到這個錄音的話
我覺得我們想到那個ID
對你還蠻有幫助的
因為我有機器
我有武器
你來用的話應該會用的比我們更好
好啦
所以今天這一集就是
我對這本書的一個想法跟心得
這也算是我第一次幫人家做心得分享
我有幫雨農寫過去了
但是做心得分享是導師第一次
這本書真的不錯
我值得我推薦大家去買
那我再讲一次
就是说这本书里面
前面第一部跟第二部
请先看两遍
然后再看最后一部
你会有很多不同的想法
好
那今天就先到此结束
因为不开放Q&A
我等一下下楼去送人
我们家有访客
好
那杨树开场我们就下次见
谢谢大家
拜拜